[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'suis demain elle m'avait vous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
shammo là
parce que papa
j'ai envie de nous bourrer de commencer
en vous disant que 4 en 1 les
montréalaises et les montréalais ont ils
eu la première mairesse de l'histoire de
la vie devant elle
papa
et que ce soir et nous disent à nouveau
oui cette mère s on veut continuer à
travailler avec elle on lui fait
confiance
mais laissez moi vous dire que ce soir
on marque à nouveau l'histoire on va
encore plus loin parce que pour la
première fois
montréal sera dirigée par deux femmes
vivez comme il est
[Applaudissements]
oui voilà deux femmes valérie et
dominique ollivier qui sera la nouvelle
présidente du comité exécutif de la
ville de montréal
elle est maria les montréalaises ont
également décidé de porter au pouvoir à
nouveau une équipe qui renouveler qui
est diversifiée qui est à l'image de la
population et sa halle au lendemain
notre élection en 2017 c'était ça le
pari de projet montréal on s'est dit oui
notre équipe sera plus diversifiée
encore pour être à l'image du montréal
d'aujourd'hui mais également le montréal
de demain
[Applaudissements]
alors opté ce soir clairement b janvier
vous dire qu'on va mettre tous les
efforts on va mettre tous les efforts du
mans pour contenu faire de montréal une
ville dont on est fier où on peut élever
nos enfants
étudier travailler et vivre notre
retraite de façon active en fait ce que
les montréalais et les montréalaises ont
confirmé ce soir c'est que l'élection de
projet montréal en 2017 ce n'était pas
un accident parcours
[Applaudissements]
why
que c'était en fait le début d'une
nouvelle ère d'une façon de gouverner
montréal de façon différente en prenant
les décisions que le court terme mais
aussi pour le long terme en étant
transparent et en effectuer oui et en
effectuer à aa et en effectuant
en effectuant des changements qui sont
nécessaires pour tous les citoyennes et
tous les citoyens et que oui on peut
diriger la ville de montréal avec le
sourire
à moi j'ai envie de sourire toujours et
encore plus mais je vais nous encourager
à continuer à sourire parce que la vie
elle est belle plus belle en souriant
même quand il est moments plus
difficiles il y avait une chanson qui
disait c'est plus facile en chantant
mais moi j'ai envie de dire c'est plus
facile en souriant
mais non à toutes les personnes qui ont
voté pour nous pour projet montréal ce
que je vous dis c'est qu'on va être
fidèle à nos paroles mais également
notre vision pour nous ça c'est très
important
nos valeurs et son on les vit dans l'eau
dans tous les arrondissements chaque
personne tous les candidats candidate
tous les élus porte ces valeurs très
très forte est ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va travailler fort tous les jours
pour vraiment améliorer la qualité de
vie de tout le monde sur l'île peu
importe où est-ce qu'on est à celles et
ceux qui ont voté pour d'autres
candidats
mon message c'est celui ci je saurai la
mairesse de toutes les montréalaises et
de tous les montréalais pique notre
équipe doit être à l'écouté de toute la
population de chacun des arrondissements
de montréal on vous tend la main qui est
ensemble on va bâtir le montréal
d'aujourd'hui le montréal de demain et
ce c'est possible parce que quand on
travaille ensemble on fait de grandes
choses c'est très important
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en me rendant ici tout à l'heure j'ai
bien sûr j'ai appelé mes collègues
monsieur coderre et monsieur r je n'ai
pas réussi à les rejoindre chez vraiment
merci
[Applaudissements]
la ligue la ligue était occupée
c'est vrai
[Rires]
le vin bonne blague
mais les
l'important c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'était un point important
pour moi
de les zapper je sais qu'on va se parler
dans les prochaines heures et tant mieux
c'est important parce que je veux
vraiment leur dire tout d'abord les
féliciter pour leur campagne c'est
important se lance en politique c'est en
soit quand même dont un seul don de soi
vous le savez l'autre ça manque de
travail de l'énergie
donc ce que je souhaite vraiment c'est
de leur dire et de je veux qu'ils
sachent que nous dans le prochain mandat
comme on les fait pendant le premier
mandat on va travailler avec tous les
élus peu importe le parti parce qu'à
partir de maintenant de maintenant la
campagne est derrière nous donc on
avance j'ai également remercier du fond
du coeur tous les bénévoles qui ont
travaillé sans relâche pendant sept ans
hahaha
avant
affaire
je vais vous dire chers bénévoles ceux
qui sont ici ce soir ceux qui sont à la
maison ceux qui sont dans les différents
locaux électoraux dans les
arrondissements que cette victoire là
c'est la note elle est à nous elle est
annoncé
chez également à remercier à celui tous
les candidats et candidates encore une
fois tous partis confondus qui se sont
présentées la démocratie a besoin de
femmes et d'hommes qui vraiment qui
donne une partie de leur vie surtout
pour faire une campagne on sait comment
cet exigeant pour vraiment mener à terme
cet exercice démocratique et c'est très
important alors bravo à toutes celles et
ceux qui se sont présentés bravo
[Applaudissements]
enfin
je veux également félicité les mairesses
et les marquis ont été élus ce soir dans
les autres villes du québec
c'est important savoir que les liens qui
unissent nos vies sont très forts ils
sont nombreux
on se complète il permettez moi de dire
toutes les villes du québec on se
complète on se renforce et sachez que
les métropoles économiques et
culturelles du québec sera votre allié
face aux défis qui nous touche qui
touchent toutes nos collectivités alors
j'ai très hâte de continuer à travailler
avec vous
[Applaudissements]
parlant des filles
je peux pas passer sous silence
l'immense défi collectif auquel on a dû
faire face au cours des 18 derniers mois
vous savez quand la population de
montréal nous apportons au pouvoir il ya
quatre ans évidemment que je savais
qu'on avait une énorme responsabilité
celle de faire fonctionner la ville tout
en y apportant des changements concrets
est absolument nécessaire puis le 13
mars 20 20 tout a été chamboulé tout à
coup c'était plus du tout le même un
support tout avait changé
presque dans un claquement de doigts
dans les rues désertes centre ville j'ai
réalisé que mon rôle de mairesse ne
change et que ma première responsabilité
était maintenant d'assurer la sécurité
de tout le monde en laissant personne
derrière dans cette bataille là contre
la pandémie que personne n'avait jamais
personne avait été confronté à une
pandémie comme ça bercy avait pas de
marche à suivre ben on s'est serré les
coudes les moria les montréalais se sont
serré les coudes
on a soutenu ceux et celles qui avait
pas de toit que pour se réfugier on a
créé des restes osseux rapide pour
organiser de l'aide alimentaire pour
organiser le dépistage ou encore l'
isolement préventif
puis quand je parle du o2 qui est ce que
je parle mais je parle des policiers des
pompiers de toute la grande famille de
la ville de montréal qui s'est adaptée
que continue à assurer tous les services
essentiels aux citoyens malgré
l'incertitude et la peur tout le monde a
participé à cette immense effort je suis
très fier d'avoir été la capitaine de ce
grand navire pendant ces moments
difficiles
[Applaudissements]
savez vous ce que cette pandémie cette
façon de gérer la crise me confirmer
c'est qu'une société qui est plus
égalitaire
résistent mieux aux turbulences
[Applaudissements]
ce que ça me prouver ses claviers de
montréal peut faire face à tous les
défis incluant le défi écologique parce
que ça aussi ça nous guette oui et pour
y arriver il faut tous et toutes on
travaille ensemble et ça on est prêt à
le faire on est prêt à aller de l'avant
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi dans les quatre
prochaines années
mais ça va être déterminant ça va être
déterminant pour montréal on a une
chance une et d'accélérer notre ancien
co logique est de positionner la ville
de montréal à l'avant guerre mondiale de
l'économie du futur ça c'est important
on peut pas faire tout tout seul c'est
impossible tout le monde doit mettre
l'épaule à la roue je danse je lance
donc un appel à la population
je lance une invitation au milieu des
affaires au milieu universitaire à
québec à ottawa à toutes les forces
vives de notre ville je vous invite à
vous joindre à mon équipe pour
qu'ensemble on construisait montréal qui
est vert qui est innovant un montréal où
les logements sont abordables où les
rues sont sécuritaires ou les espaces
verts sont nombreux où les moyens de
transport sont diversifiées efficace ou
le centre-ville et dean avait dynamique
et où la vie de quartier et les
vibrantes c'est à ça que je vous convie
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
la bonne nouvelle c'est que cette
campagne nous a prouvé que c'est ce que
les citoyennes et les citoyens veulent
et la bonne nouvelle également c'est que
tous ces efforts qu'on ait mis en place
et qu'on va continuer à mettre en place
mais c'est ce qui attire chez nous les
étudiants les talents des entreprises à
travers le monde c'est ce qui fait de
montréal est une ville unique sur la
planète où les débouchés sont nombreux
où l'économie roule à fond quand on
assure en fait ce qui me confirme que
quand on assure réellement la mixité
sociale économique culturelle et
générationnelle dans nos quartiers ce
sont tous les gens qui choisissent
d'habiter puis travailler à montréal qui
en sortent gagnants et sont pour moi ces
sommes la force de montréal vraiment
alors mes amis ce soir en fait ce sont
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais dès demain matin dès demain matin
on va continuer à transformer notre
vision en réalité comme on le fait au
caire au cours des quatre dernières
années et on va continuer à le faire on
va travailler d'arrache-pied pour
construire à montréal dont on est fiers
et qu'on veut léguer aux prochaines
générations
de saint laurent avait redonne du sud
ouest et du sud ouest en plein quartier
v
ah ah
on veut montréal qui est enviée par le
monde entier pour sa qualité de vie et
ses valeurs écologiques de pierrefonds
roxboro à rosemont la petite patrie je
viens
[Applaudissements]
du plateau mont royal à saint léonard
montréal qui est d'abord d'ordre
sécuritaire et accessible
deux marées alors là outremonde la
chesnaie mercier hochelaga maisonneuve
un mariage où notre langue commune et le
français et où la culture est riche et
vivante
de côte-des-neiges-notre-dame-de-grâce
anjou à part ça en passant par rivière
des prairies pointe aux trembles
[Musique]
à montréal où l'économie est verte et et
innovante de la salle amélie villeray
saint michel parc social
et de ville-marie à l'île bizard sainte
geneviève
[Musique]
on veut montréal pour aujourd'hui à
montréal
merci